[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali.
Today, we're going to be talking
about the Google Drive
SDK and two features we launched
yesterday that I'm
really proud of, I'm really
happy for, and hopefully, I'll
explain them to you today, and
explain why I'm so happy.
And then we're going to
look at some code,
which is always fun.
I just want to show you how
easy it is to use them.
So what are these
two features?
Well, we want Drive to be
used as a platform.
It's not a full cloud platform
like App Engine, for example,
but it has a lot of the
components you need.
And anytime you want to store
files in your application, we
think you should have
a Drive component.
Now, there were two things
missing here.
One of them was the ability
to add custom
properties to files.
Very simple, take any file
in Drive and add your own
properties to it, a custom set
of key value pairs that you
can use for anything.
It can be a rating system,
the number of stars.
You can arbitrarily tag files.
That's a feature we've had again
and again and again so
you can put your own tags on
there, things like that.
The second feature we've
launched is what we're calling
Application Data.
Now, that is files in Drive that
only your application can
modify, update, create,
and delete.
When I say only your file,
obviously, they
belong to the user.
The user can see how much
storage you're using there,
how much of their quota is being
used, and they can then
delete these files.
But they can't modify them.
So I think together, these two
offer up real platform
opportunities.
Think, for the Application Data,
something like saving a
game, for example.
You don't want the user to be
able to modify the game state.
That's cheating.
So this is hidden from them
and if they're saying it's
using too much storage,
you can get rid of it.
Those are the two features.
Now, let's dive immediately
into the code.
I just want to show you
how to do them.
We're going to use Python,
and we're going
to start from scratch.
So the first thing we're going
to do is create a virtual
environment.
Done.
And then we're going to install
the Python Client
Library and a nice interpreter
to you can see what I'm doing.
Install.
This is how easy it is to use
our Python Client Library.
You install it with pip.
Anyone who's used Python
before knows that.
It's going to download them.
And while I'm waiting for that
to happen, I'll talk to you
about what code we're
going to write.
First, we're going to look at
just some examples of how to
create custom properties
on a file.
So we'll create a file and
then we'll add custom
properties to it.
I'll show you the different
types of property.
And then we're going to use the
Application Data folder to
store some hidden stuff, and
then see what it looks like
for your users in Drive.
OK, great.
So, let's start the
interpreter.
And there we are.
As usual for these demos, I'm
going to cheat a bit.
I've already got an authorized
Drive client.
What you need to do is run the
user through the overflow, and
either store their token, or if
it's a web app, do it every
time and save it in
your database.
That's absolutely fine.
But Drive, you'll have to take
my word for it, is a fully
authorized Drive service from
the Python Client Library.
In addition to the normal scope,
worth mentioning here,
I've asked for an extra scope
that is specifically the app
data scope.
Now your app needs to
specifically ask for
authorization on that scope.
Why didn't we just bundle it
into the full Drive scope?
Well, when a user has already
authorized some degree of
permissions to their data, you
can't then go and add extra
things onto that.
That's wrong, because the
user clicked "OK" for
these various things.
So that's one of the reasons.
Apart from that, I think it's
useful for an application to
be able to request
just this scope.
All it's going to do is add this
kind of application data.
And it doesn't want to modify
it or look at any of your
other files.
So I think that's great.
I think it's really useful to
scope it as finely as you can.
So first thing we're going to
do is insert a file because
we're going to add some
properties to it.
So let's have a look.
We don't actually need
the body of the file.
Let's give it a title here,
test properties.
And there's our file.
I want to store the file ID so
that I can use it later.
So let's just get it out
of the last one.
And there we go.
That's the file ID.
So I'm going to be adding
properties to this.
Now, imagine a totally
contrived example.
We'll go into real examples
later, but a
totally contrived example.
I like to know the fruitiness
of my files.
And how do I specify
the fruitiness?
Well, I give it a value.
So a small value for me is
fruitiness banana, for example.
That's quite fruity.
Very fruity, I'm going
to use melon.
So the first thing we're going
to do is add a property for
the fruitiness of this file.
So drive.files--
sorry, drive.properties.insert.
And we always parse
the file ID.
And then in the body, we
parse our property.
And the property should
have a key.
Let's have it "fruitiness."
Let's just call it "fruit."
And a value--
and the value here, well,
we're going to go for
"banana." So drive dot files dot
this, and don't forget to
execute that.
And there we go.
So we have created this, and if
you look at the output of
this property, you'll
see that there's a
value, there's the key.
And something you'll notice
right in the middle there is
the visibility.
Now, custom properties on
files have a private
visibility and a public
visibility.
What does this mean?
Well, it's nothing to do with
what the user can see.
Of course, it's the user's data,
so that's all theirs.
Whether it's private to other
users of public to other users
is based on the sharing
module in Drive.
So users can go and
share that.
This private means it's private
for your application.
Can you imagine a situation
where different applications
would like to share this data?
Well, they can.
If there's a workflow
application,
say you have a document.
It needs to be reviewed by five
people as it goes through
various approval stages.
That is an example where
different applications can
update the same data.
So that's where it could be
public, a use case there.
I'm just going to use private.
And the default visibility
for all your
operations is private anyway.
So we're going to do that.
OK, so there we go.
We have that.
And then let's have a look.
We want to be able to list--
drive.properties.list--
and this will just list the
properties on a file.
Kind of useful, there you go.
This time we get a list of
items, each one of those a
property object.
And we've only got one,
so it's there.
OK, great.
What do I want to do next?
Well, let's update
this property.
You've seen this kind of
thing before, standard,
drive.properties.update.
This time, we parse
the file ID.
And again, we need
to parse the new
updated property object.
So key, fruit, and also, we
parse the property key in the
request URL as a parameter
so that it knows
which ones it's getting.
And we've got a bit of
a craziness there.
Property key equals fruit.
Body equals key, fruit.
Value--
wow, this has gone crazy,
but never mind.
Value, this time we'll go for
"melon." Now if this works,
it'll be a miracle.
Excellent.
There we go.
It has worked, so miracles
do happen.
Let's list our properties again,
just to make sure.
And there it is.
So now, we have the updated,
just to show you how I'm not
cheating, with the value
"melon." Really easy, create
properties, update them,
arbitrary key value store, can
be visible to your app or
visibility public so that all
applications can read it.
Perfect.
And it's a perfect use case.
Store your ratings, store custom
tags, store the ID that
this file represents
in your database.
That will save you
a round trip.
So every time you get the file,
you immediately know
what it corresponds to
in your database.
You might have loads of data
that you want to store off
Google Drive.
Absolutely fine.
So that's properties quickly.
Right.
Now on to application data, a
bit more interesting, perhaps.
I can think of many,
many use cases.
Mobile use cases come
to mind to hugely.
You have configuration file
for your mobile app.
You want to store it somewhere
where it will be synchronized
and consistently distributed
to all running
instances of this app.
And few, not many users--
most users are going towards
having multiple--
even multiple mobile devices,
so a tablet, a
phone, I have a laptop.
I want this configuration data
synchronized, and I want it
the same everywhere.
I expect that.
I'm starting to expect
that as a user.
So your application
should cover this.
OK, so how does that work?
Well, we have added an alias
to a specific folder inside
Google Drive.
So wherever you might
put a folder ID--
in Drive, for example,
inserting a file--
you can now put the alias
"appdata." One word,
A-P-P-D-A-T-A. I'll show
you in a second.
So you can use that alias, and
that will automatically get
you to the application data.
OK, really cool.
Let's create a file in there.
We're just going to use
drive.files.insert again.
Now, this time, let's
give it a body.
The title doesn't really matter,
because obviously, the
user can't see this.
So it's just a way that you
might be able to look up your
file or check it later.
App data test--
OK.
And this time--
let's pause for a second.
This time, we want to give
it some kind of volume.
We want to give it some data,
because I want you to see how
it plays in the Drive
user interface.
Actually, you can just use a
shortcut file, which doesn't
have any data, but then you
wouldn't be able to put any
information in it.
More on that later, but-- so
from API client, dot HTTP,
import media in memory.
And we'll create a media body.
So media body equals media
in memory upload.
Hello GDL--
that's going to be the title.
And text, plain, we'll
give it a MIME type.
And this time we'll insert
with that body
and this media body.
A media body just controls
what file
you're going to upload.
I'm just grabbing a bit
of text from memory.
Obviously it can be a real file,
if you have that on disk
or wherever.
So media body equals that.
OK, and there we go.
It's created the file.
So let's give it another
name, because FID
we're already using.
So let's call it RID equals.
So this is the ID of the file
you've created in appdata.
Let's just quickly go over
to Drive, and we'll see.
So what I've done there--
intentional mistake, of course,
and you can see the
file after I'd spend half
an hour telling
you that you can't--
is actually I just created
a regular file.
I didn't put it in
the right place.
Newbie error, but that's OK.
Let's delete it and try again.
So this time, I want to make
sure that it's going into the
correct folder.
OK, how do I do that?
Well, you can create it,
add it there later.
The quickest way actually is
to parse the parents list.
So this is a list of parents.
Whoa.
OK, it's going to
hate me today.
I'm just going to restart
the shell.
Sorry, just re-import
the stuff.
That's OK.
Media body, we'll create
the media body again.
It's good because I got to show
you how to do this twice,
which makes me really happy.
Hello GDL, and the MIME
type, text plain, and
drive.files().insert--
OK.
So this time, body equals, we're
just going to put the
parents in.
So parents, and that's a list
of parents, so each one just
needs an ID.
And we're going to use
for the ID appdata.
See that?
And then we're going to parse
the media body as well, the
one we created.
So this time hopefully it will
create a hidden file.
It won't create a regular file
that you can just see.
And there we go.
FID equals that.
I just want to store the ID so
I have to mess around later.
So there we go.
Let's go back here again.
And you see, amazingly,
nothing has appeared.
was our properties file,
but we haven't
created a new one here.
And why?
It's actually now hidden behind
the Manage Apps dialog.
So we open Manage Apps.
It shows all the files that
are connected to you
application.
That's really great.
Whether they're connected--
this is an Android app at
the top, and various
other Google Apps.
But as we can see at the bottom
here, you have my Test
Python Push Client that is
now storing one kilobyte
of hidden app data.
It's not actually one kilobyte,
but that's the
lowest term.
So there I've got some data.
That's awesome.
What can I do with it?
Well I'm fed up with it.
I just want to delete it.
I've cleared it out now, and
it's not using any of my
[? creator. ?]
You can see that
it's now empty.
So that's the flow
for the user.
Really simple.
Just remember, every time you're
using a folder ID, you
can just parse the appdata
ID instead.
Now, that does take a
lookup on our end.
So you know this isn't
going to change.
A user only has one app data
folder for your application.
So you can easily just
cache that ID.
Save it, so that would make
everything quicker.
That's really up to you.
So that would be this ID here.
I would just store that in my
database, maybe, if I wanted
to optimize and make
it a bit quicker.
But for most cases, just
parsing app data
is absolutely fine.
OK, great.
So what have we done?
We've created some custom
properties, and we've shown
you how to hide data, or make
data so that the user
can only delete it.
Why don't we combine
both of these?
That seems perfect to me.
So we can create a file, doesn't
necessarily have to
have any content to it.
But we can use the properties
to actually use as the
configuration values
of that file.
So suddenly I've got a hidden
file with custom properties
that are my configuration
values.
OK, fantastic.
Let's do that.
So now,
drive.properties().insert.
So fileId calls fid.
Body equals key.
This time, let's do
a proper one.
I don't know, last name.
That could be my last
name or something.
Value, so that's
me, of course.
So we parse that body
and execute.
And no.
I'm getting a 404 there.
So it seems that you can't
actually put these properties
at the moment on
a custom file.
So that's a shame.
It would have been nice to bring
them together so you
could see it.
We should probably
aim for that.
I guess it was a bit too much
to wish for that we could
store free stuff in
the app data.
So unfortunately we
can't do that.
I could keep trying, but I think
that's going to be a
problem there.
OK, so custom properties, add
whatever you like to the file.
You can't store loads
and loads of stuff.
It's not a full database, but
it's perfect, perfect for your
light examples.
Application data, hide stuff
from the user so they
can't modify it.
They can delete it.
They still own it.
It's still theirs.
It's not an evil thing,
I promise.
It's still theirs.
It can track you.
And they can manage it through
this Manage Apps dialog here.
Our commitment to you to be able
to use Drive for whatever
use case you'd like
as a platform--
really, I think we're gradually
getting there where
we have these features
that you can't really
find anywhere else.
Perfect for building small
integrations, large
integrations, whatever you like,
however this best suits
your application.
So we'll see you next time.
If you've got any questions,
please ask them on Stack
Overflow or drop along
to our G+ community.
It's very lively there.
Everyone will be happy to chat
with you about these things.
And it was great
talking to you.
Thanks very much.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]